Desperate times call for desperate measures, and
times are really desperate right now for Fox News
Channel. Now, you might be wondering why what's
going on? Why are things so desperate for Fox?
Fox News attached their wagon,
so to speak, to the wrong horse.
That horse being Donald Trump and Donald Trump
lost the election badly and then humiliated
himself and the American right by waging the
wacky, baseless fight to try to steal the election
from the rightful winner, Joe Biden, that we all
observed together for a period of several months.
And this had a number of different repercussions.
It led to many Republicans abandoning the
Republican Party, but it also led to lots of Fox
News viewers leaving Fox News for OCN and Newsmax,
which more reliably welcomed and pushed
and entertained any and every harebrained
conspiracy theory about the election. So Fox News
is ad dollars are collapsing. Ratings for some of
their key shows are way down from before the
election, including the Sean Hannity program.
And Fox News is in a panic. What do they
do? What do we do? They have been asking.
So they are going back to the strategy that
got them to where they are in the first place.
Manufactured scandals about Democratic
politicians, think Benghazi, think Obama's
tan suit, think the war on Christmas, migrant
caravan's at convenient times, that type of
thing. And the new one on Tucker Carlson's show.
This is just something else. The new one that
Tucker has concocted with his producers is that
the relationship between Joe and Jill Biden,
that appears to be a loving relationship, a
seeming return to a couple that likes each other,
which is a big change from Donald and Melania
Trump's relationship. The claim is that Jill
and Joe Biden's relationship is actually a
fake stage managed public relations campaign.
Take a look at this.
At the heart of this great American family
is a love story. One man, one woman, and the fires
of passion that changed the course of our history.
Not since Anthony dine with Cleopatra in downtown
Antioch before they killed themselves, obviously
as a country witnessed a love story as
moving and poignant as Jill and Joe's
No. Ladies and gentlemen, Jill Biden is
not Joe's caretaker. She isn't his nurse.
She's as fully equal romantic partner together.
They are like besotted teens. Yet at the same time
they are the wise and knowing parents of a nation.
As a headline from Politico on Valentine's Day,
put it, quote, Historians and relationship experts
agree the first couple's romantic gestures aren't
just genuine, they're restorative. So it's
official. The Biden's affection is totally
real. It's in no way part of a slick PR campaign
devised by cynical consultants determined to hide
the president's senility by misdirection. Not at
all. Their love is this real is climate change.
So I have a few thoughts on this. This is an
example. Of the performative outrage that we
talked about last week, among the right of
finding things to be outraged about that
are just ridiculous. And secondly, understand
that this doesn't get on TV on a whim.
I don't know exactly how many minutes of
commercials there are during Tucker Carlson
show, but if it's similar to many other cable
news shows, you know, it's somewhere between
18 and 23 minutes of commercials. That leaves
about 37 or so minutes of content. Every
single one of those 37 minutes is very highly
produced, meaning that this story was pitched
at some kind of morning meeting. And as a group,
they decided, yes, let's go with this story. Let's
go with this story about Joe and Jill Biden's
relationship being some kind of fake act. And
then, of course, being Tucker he has to throw in
their relationship is as real as climate change,
which is part of how they are packing up,
packaging up their response to the Texas
power outages, which we talked about earlier
in the show, to blame wind power and claim
that climate change is fake. But understand the
other part of why they're actually doing this.
They are panicking because not only is there
a guy out of power and not only have their
guy's followers increasingly opted for Newsmax
and 018 because Fox coverage apparently isn't
crazy enough, people also like what Joe Biden is
doing. And this has Fox News in an absolute tizzy.
Joe Biden has the highest initial approval
rating of any president in twenty eight years.
Fox News is panicking because of that.
Joe Biden has 69 percent approval on his
handling of covid under Joe Biden, average
daily vaccinations have gone from 890000
on Trump's last day in office to one point
seven million vaccinations a day and continuing
to climb. That's that's basically doubling in 26
days in office. And they continue to accelerate.
Joe Biden is apparently eventually going to
get covid relief done without Republicans. And
the country wants covid relief. But Fox News just
continues to interview Republicans who are against
it. So Fox News has to manufacture something
and this is what they've chosen to go with.
Now, is this going to work to pull audiences
back from 08? CNN, Newsmax? I have no idea.
It's hard for me to put myself in the mindset of
what someone who used to watch Fox News but was
lured away by Newsmax and owned like what exactly
do they want? What are they looking for? I don't
know. It's hard for me to imagine what would
bring them back, since to me it's crazy to have
been lured away in the first place.
But this appears to be the way
that many Fox News programs are going. And we
predicted they would go back to the same stuff,
the equivalent of the Obama wore a tan suit
and like the wrong mustard type of thing, the
manufactured scandals, the fake or performative
outrage they're doing, the debt and deficit, small
government, the war on Christmas and religious
freedom, all of these different things that they
abandoned for the most part during Donald Trump's
presidency. So we'll see what Fox next. Fox News
looks like in two months. We're already starting
to get a sense of the playbook they're going back
to in the aftermath of the Trump presidency. And
then the next question will be, if Fox does a what
is it that Newsmax and OCN will do? I don't know
the answer, but it's going to be some wild times